i'm very glad to be here to present your
our activity of the
panasonic collaborative rnd
and
the this the better life in a better
world
is in fact here
our new slogan
from the uh thank you
new president
uh mr suga
uh here i show you the content of my
presentation
and uh in the beginning of the year i
explained here uh what where are the new
panasonic is moving because here this uh
last two
two years we have a big loss
in our in my company and then the year
after the
uh
july and last year
our new president sugar
has been the uh many are changing
to recover our company
so the uh
first i will show you this some
situation
and after that uh
to
realize the uh that uh future the rnd
also
played a big ball
so
to do so the
our approach to realize such kind of r d
we adopted the op innovation method so
after that i show you our uh activity of
the of innovation
uh this is a message of the uh from
triga
uh
in a panasonic business policy meeting
in the in this fiscal year
and so far the
panasonic
has had a
constant on the consumer electronics
but right now the panasonic is not just
the tv maker
so far we have many uh assets of the
technology of the uh
technology and uh business model in the
consumer electronics
and the we use the uh of this uh asset
to expand our business
uh in the various industry area
uh for example the
housing
society and the business and journey
and the automobile
and we provide the uh we collaborate
with the uh the the personal company
in those areas and then to create the a
better life
to the
each customers
and from this april uh our uh
business group
consists of the four companies
one is the appliance companies and the
rx solution company and every network
company
and the automotive and the industrial
system company
so those companies covered
those the new uh industrial area
uh this is the uh
uh showing that our
four four strategic
area
in our in our business
and we are now addressed as a group
one is the resident space and the second
one known residence space the mobility
and the personal
in that case the
we set up the uh
cloud
is a very key technology
to uh to go go beyond or go expanding in
the
those areas in a business
for example there are in a resin space
they
are connecting with their
appliance good
they request the
new functions
or new design
for the uh audio appliance good so
that's causing a new business
and also known for the non-resident
space the adult connection with the
project
that much that might give us their uh
solution or a service business
the familiar mobility area the
uh
by using the cloud
uh we will expand the uh business
in the automobile and
aviation
in the more
for personal the connection with this
project
might be give us the new business for
the accessory of applications
so the other first step
we're going to focus on the uh
toothpaste residential space and the
mobility first because the uh those area
is maybe the best advocate for the
transfer the other asset of the
technology
of their consumer tonics
then
i'll show you the uh
mission of the around corporate reading
so what should rnd create
the mission of the uh orange rnd
is
to create an uh technology to sustain
the future business
maybe the under five years or ten years
later
however the we have we are facing with a
very uh big problems
uh first one is the uh
short product
lifetime in this is especially for the
digital product
if the product can be made by anyone the
immediately those market will be a
red ocean
and the second one is the uncertain
uncertainty of of the research themes
for the future business
probably at this moment
no one can be uh said
about the guarantee i would uh this
topic is you know promising or not
so those two our problems are really has
a headache of the uh
think about the new new topics
this
slide shows the some evidence for the
short product lifetime
so that as i told you the
digitalization has brought the high
price competition
so the investment of the recovery
uh has been getting hard
so uh left side showed the uh the
example of the record player and the
right side is a mobile phone
so this is the price and this year's as
you can see the the the half-life
of the
vs video
is around 10 years
however the uh for dvd player case half
rise of four years
and the dvd break of the case even worse
in the half a half lives two years
and the mobile phone case on this axis
the number of the unit in our market and
this one also the years
the the here i showed the period
between the uh the beginning of the
market and also the
time of the maximum
numbers
as you can see this period also getting
decreased
even if the
function
of the mobile phone is getting better
and better
however this kind of
short lifetime is a
occurred
so
how
so how do we overcome the this kind of
program
so uh
strategy over r d
is also the uh of course we have to
follow the uh strategy of the uh our
group
so
uh we're gonna focus on the uh
two areas
other
topics one is uh uh housing and the
other is the automobile
and that's also the uh uh
uh hostel connected by the cloud
they give us here some service over you
know a new business
for the uh uh
collaborating with the b2b partner and
they give the
better life to the customers
and also we have to think about how to
overcome the
present
current problems
so there may be many methods
right here i show you the uh our one
method which is the uh adopting the uh
of innovation
here are
other observations
we tried three different uh
approaches one is the academia
and the other collaborative
interventions and the third one is the
collaborating with the ireland platforms
here i show you the uh current parameter
as i mentioned before
so to
overcome the uh this current problem
i think there are uh
the four and three items
are necessary
first one is the
high-speed
rnd
to transfer the product to the
market as fast as possible
because
we need some you know take assignment
advantage uh first movers advantage
and second one since we don't know the
uh which topics is uh are promising or
not so
we should do the uh many attention
by the new themes
and third one is uh
implementation
of the x system i guess
this goes the uh this will bring the uh
uh two things
one is uh
uh
i'll say one is that
no uh one company
can make
all of technology for the product in
this day
so the existing is maybe necessary
and also that we need a
high barrier
to entry
of the competitor company
so
to realize these three items
i'm sure the offer of innovation
is unnecessary
yeah we so far we
we have done the three type of the uh
approach for as a open innovation
collaboration with the academia
in this case mainly the academia is our
university and we work with the summit
professor
the professor has a very high level you
know skill
and uh saudia uh we
asked ask him or collaborate with the uh
try to very at risk themes
and then we we better several uh topics
to the uh you know different professor
or different university
the collaboration second was the
collaboration with the ventures
in this case uh
we used a
corporate venturing
and then the uh we
adopted the technology
to
to make uh our whole system
sometimes their technology is
complementary
of the our technology so it's a kind of
small size ecosystem
and also in that case we paid
we paid the money
to to
to buy the
time
instead of the eye
instead of the
uh
rnd by myself
and third one is a collaboration with a
orange partner
usually the rn partner has their own
technology and also they have a nice
facility
so if we have a nice topics
we can collaborate with the those
partners
and then the uh
we combined their technology and our
technology
using their facility
so it's called the satellite rnd and
also the since they have a
nice technology so they they can easily
make a ecosystem
so uh so so let me
show you the uh uh those three items
uh
using the concrete topics
this is a one
example of the collaboration with
academia
i should stanford university
maybe you know mona i
several years ago we joined here our uh
me 310
which is academia industry program
and then we send our i'm employed to the
artist program
and studying the under the professor
lifer
to my knowledge the this uh
house's
program
has a following policy
one is the creation of the new concept
for the instrument and also by uh
violation
by the rapid prototyping
i heard you this uh this concept is uh
origin of the idea
so
those
collaboration
with the university
we learned
some idea or some concept of the
user interface
so
this means you're helping to support
that program you're giving them project
ideas
yeah we carry that
okay
and are you actually sending people to
participate in this do you know yes uh
in fact we have a laboratory in our
cupertino and the member of that office
joined this program yeah
sometimes you know our member also
visits here but not nothing regularly
here's one example
to further uh
using the uh new interface for the
remote controller we saw we saw what we
called the easy touch remote
as you can see this kind of control like
a game game style
but you see that
there are very few
are buttoned
compared to the conventional remote
control of the tv set
and also the uh they use a both hand
so there are many houses a combination
to to do so saudia these are
uh
remote control is a
very uh easy
to use the uh uh controller display
the unfortunately uh
this one is not a product yet but uh
some of the parts are
really transferred real the product
yeah okay yeah so the idea is uh
sometimes directly or indirectly yeah
and this one is a
holographic display
and uh
although the technology of the
holographic is used for the three 3d
display
and also there are natural free space
interface is a kind of new ui
like a gesture
uh ui
so using the uh this kind of the uh
concept
we can design of the house
town
or and also the small size cases are
mobile phone designing
and third one is a gesture ui
applies to the
automobile
so consistent and a simple ui
and the interaction model to reduce the
drivers disruption
so probably the uh this kind of the
user interface
is uh
available at the time of the year
uh cloud cloud also the uh probably the
uh
working working with the those ui
another example of the
collaboration with academia
so-called industry on campus
it was a
proposed by the osaka university in
japan it's close to the my company's
head office
the policies that are hand-in-hand with
the industry
of university creativity and the new
front
frontier for the industry
uh
they they made a collaborative research
center
at this building
so this building
exists in the campus
however the uh so that
uh theme
of this uh center
is
uh
coming from the
industry
and then the uh
they provide us some
office just office
and then the company send the people to
the door's office and bring bringing
their
theme
and the resource
is uh so industry and the university so
we can ask the university professor or
we can use the
student to
the places of the university and the
facilities mainly they are we can use
the university facility but sometimes we
carry in our facility too
and so technology is you know some
mixing
between the university and industry
now we we have started from the uh
this center from the uh
uh april in the last year
uh next one is a
collaboration with the ventures
yeah as a uh
collaborating with the adventures we're
doing the uh
corporate venturing
since the uh 1998
which
which is down the bay area in the united
states and also all cycle japan
in this case
we became a insider of the silicon
valley venture community
by doing the minority investment in
startup companies
as shared uh
as a shareholder
we promote a strategic collaboration
such as joint development and this is
the
our patina office
today the two guys are from the uh this
office so if you have some questions
they can answer there
here i show you the uh corporate
venturing framework of the operation
so first step is the searching for the
uh
good
or high potential sub startups
and the second one is the uh
uh if it
works well we will promote or support to
the uh collaboration with those venture
companies
and then
uh
as a third step
we will do the strategic investment
and finally there are
uh we'll move on to the monitoring of
the portfolio uh
management
to to maximize the uh
uh house
investment
in our technology point of view
here i'll show you the uh
policy of the portfolio
we define the two axis
as a portfolio one is the
gross axis and the other the technology
axis
as a growth axis the
uh
we show uh we consider the uh the
progress
of the each venture uh companies
so private and or mnda or the
public
as a technology access we have of five
kind of the area
one is the network communication
a semicond sim content chipset the
service and software
the energy healthcare and the materials
and the electric electronic devices
so using the those uh portfolio uh
uh
we think the uh this is uh this is
called the less investment loss
and also the blood coverage of the
technologies
uh here i show you the the number of the
company for the each field
so totally right now the 16 companies
and i'm sorry i can't tell you the
the name of the companies but
right now we have this kind of the uh
our company working with them
and the third one is a collaboration
with our rnd partner
uh other department uh i here i
introduced the
uh collaboration
with a imac
i mean now they are belong to the uh
belgium however they have a big facility
in a reuben belgium and also the idaho
forehand in holland
they have a following advantage
one is the world's world's greatest of
innovation
there are huge number of people
and there are many companies belong it
so the uh
their technology are have for the
ecosystem
and also they have nice facilities
panasonic has joined
this program from the uh 2004.
here i show you the the program
for the full ecosystem
uh green radio for the communication
human prosperous is uh how to
ban our lives
live
sensors life science
the sensor system
and the energy including a photovoltaic
or power devices
this
uh cool seamless is a main housing
program
let's see more for the mammoths our
sensors
and organic electronics it's the kind of
the flexible
electronics
using the
foils
uh by joining this program uh we have
several achievements so from now only i
show you this some uh
achievement
in concrete
this one is a hose achievement by the uh
uh
coast himals program
uh we have done your
world first
uh volume production of our mass
production
for the systematic side
one is a 40 nanometer low power process
at years 2007.
in that process uh we adopted uh
foreign technologies already emerging
lithography and also the sterling
technology by using the silicon germany
it will apply
to the uh
0.8.264
over 3d graphics
second one is just 32 nanometer gate
first process
at the uh 2010.
that also used the alf immersion
lithography
and we use a extremely low local
material
which has the 2.4
and also the uh
we have a special structure
using the uh halfling
high k
material and also metal gate
uh that system is lsi used for the
blu-ray recorders
and those two mass projection
were done at the was factory in japan
uh next two example is uh uh
the one using the uh uh
names uh technology
first one is a mems resonator
uh this is a cross-section of the uh
resonator and
we use the triangle pole like this
and using the
trojan vibration mode
which gives us the very very high q
factors and also the low voltage driving
this is a technology from the panasonic
and then
imec has the technology of the ultra
small package using the student german
thin film
so combining the uh these technical
technologies we achieved a very high
asset
high q factors and also nice
resonator
it was presented in the
idm 2010
second
example mems technology is the
electrostatic energy harvester for the
automotive
especially in the
oil
and this is a cross-section of the
harvester
the point technology is the two things
one is the
very stable
electrolyte
and the other is the
silicon spring
so it is electrolyte keep the
electrostatic charge
between the uh uh
silicon oxide and silicon nitride
they are covered is a surface area
and this is a kind of condenser and they
are moving this way and then the uh
the church uh
the the energy
in the
condenser are carried
actually transfer to this electrode to
the outside
so the we achieved the uh uh
5 and 500 microwatt
at 2g and
one kilohertz
we use a
shock induced resonance
this one
also they are
announced
present at a transducer 2013.
and the next two example is a
healthcare devices
first one is the uh
allowable chip for direct snip detection
the size is uh uh just half of the
name card
but which include the uh
every uh household function
within the such small area
for example the they have a mixer or pcr
pixel is a polymerization
chain reactor
or filter
and just a pump and a bubble and
detector
generally if you use the conventional
method
it takes the uh
two or three days to obtain the result
at least probability one one days
necessary
however
using the uh
this uh chipset
uh it's gonna take you just
one hour or one hour
and also the uh
if you do the uh
if this kind of chip is available
the
we're going to make your house a
tailor-made
medical treatment
here's a cross-section
of the achieve
then
i put in the blood on one drop of blood
putting here
and then then you know they pump to the
this reactor
in a reactor did they have a reagent
and then the uh from blood to the
house decomposed to
to the dna
and the after a few after filtering the
dna
only i have
a dna which held their snip
the by uh hustle
by using a reagent
the these number of the
uh
snip dna is amplified then they detect
the
so
this one is a
whole system on these two small chips
i've got to ask you a question
for uh size comparison you're showing
one european cent
right that's a very small coin
that's used in the eu
is there a european connection for this
yeah
maybe
this work with the ima okay and imac
okay that makes sense
and
second one there are actually
this is kind of the
joint press with the imac
about the
eeg sensor
which measures the
brain wave
and
the application of this one is
is a kind of difficult one but uh
in the first application is used for the
uh
tuning of the hearing aid
the people
of course here say honestly however
sometimes they the you know tuning the
hair hearing aid
are different from their real situation
so the by measuring the brain wave
we are we can you know
uh
we can get a result reproducible
reproduce stability
so we use this uh
device
and this
is a
new household device for the headset
so
it's kind of
cool right
and they have a h channel
so the uh to measure the brainwave there
are many kinds of the you know
uh
signal can be obtained
okay last two uh
examples are uh flexible
electronics
the first one is uh all the lighting
tiles
here we
really have to
maintain
the technology which is the
printing
and also they are used uh flexible
substrate because the uh we have to care
about the cost
so first one
all red fresh oled on the plastic
and the second one is uh
oled on the uh metal foil in this case
probably the
coupler
they just started from the uh this year
so the efficiency is not so high however
it's already started under reliability
in a humidity management so this is a
house
the oled
in the uh
house
bowl with water
the second one is there are flexible
display
for four inch full color
top permission versus
uh
actually matrix oled
so this this case also the we have here
uh printing technology of the old part
and then i make the time i have a
technology for the uh
oxide tft on the foil so we combined
with the other technology and then we
will realize the
flexible display
the specification
is shown in this table
and right now the uh
minimum radius
of the bending is the uh 10 millimeter
in this case also here we
really focus on the
uh
four kinds of technologies one is that
we want to keep the
top emission structure
and the second one is a
low temperature
to use is a
low cost substrate
and also the
ceiling
for against the oxygen over humidity
and and uh
this is uh the end of the of my uh
examples
and uh instead of the uh summarize my
talk dia
uh let me say again about our intention
to the future
uh here's the uh same
uh
such area as uh as a beginning
here show you the concept image in the
future
so you know for the residence area that
will provide a better life for the
happiness
and for the non-resistance period
will provide engineering the better
waters for the environmental
energy
and for the mobility will provide a
better world for their comfort
and
the personal areas will provide the
design and a better life
so would you like to
deliver a better life better world to
customers in the world
thank you thank you for your attention
so we're going to take some time for q a
i'd like to start off can i ask you to
tell a little bit more about the role of
being fellow of panasonic corporation
are you advising people on decisions
about technologies to invest in or or
what's involved
it's a very difficult question
i start with a hard one
in fact here
i can define by myself
so right now the year uh
we have a
big project
for working with the uh our company
outside the company or assa institute
so and right now i try to make some
bridge
you know between the company or
outside okay so really bridging between
the company and the outside partners or
the ventures or the academics yes okay
now i know why dr awaita insisted you
would be the right person for this
um
with all of the uncertainties about
technologies
right
you're having to identify not only
technologies to work with but also
partners to work with
what kind of things go into considering
like whether to work with imec on these
medical devices or whether to do the
work
here in the states
or somewhere else
yeah
yeah i had some experience to work with
the other company or other institute
and sometimes
uh household
yeah i'm just success why what's the
reason you know what's the difference
between them
and then
right now here what i can say is that
here
some good relation
not to take complete company maybe
people to people yeah is a very very
important
and also of course it's a natural thing
but uh
we we ration i'm going to keep it here
when we relation
that's unnecessary
yeah so especially at the beginning of a
project though you don't know what it's
really going to be like to work with the
people unless you have some sort of
experience with them right
is there any way you can hedge that risk
no
the case
we succeed
in this
at the time
we take a risk
for example the
collaboration with the other company
sometimes we're going to make a joint
development
so we send several people to there and
also company the other company also
sends it to some people right
at the time the uh
uh house there
the company don't send the
best
best people
because best people working in their own
company yeah other on other projects
yeah right
however the
uh at the time we send the best one
then
collaboration
was getting better and better
so
i think that's one way to keep the uh
win-win situation okay
so there's one other question that i
really want to ask before i open it to
the floor
and that is about inside the research
and development group inside the r d
group
a lot of these new ideas require
bringing together different knowledge
from different parts of the group
are there kind of mechanisms in place in
panasonic for the different groups to
talk to each other
or how our new projects formed up
now the uh
we try to make
such kind of the interaction
opportunity
as much as possible
in fact from two guardia he declared
that
for the group
the uh we need a
close value is very very important
because
uh right now here we have only four
companies
to to play that as a business
and then each company is a
in fact very big company so
if you have say if they want to
close their own company
they can do so yeah however the uh you
know
the
interaction for the different between
the different companies are you know
many chance to
produce a new product right
so
you know right now the uh as a
company itself try to make many
opportunities to make a such an
interaction okay okay so let's open up
the floor
beven you first
what kind of a budget in percentage of
panasonic's total budget
for your rnd
oh
is that announced or is it is that a lot
of companies announce it publicly if
it's a public company but um
if i yeah probably open number is uh for
the not only the rnd
of the
um my area
property rna or
development for the
whole group yeah
parasitic whole group did it about yeah
uh
five
five thousand
a million dollar or something like that
five billion dollars would be that the
amount in numbers
would you guess that's more or less than
10 percent of total revenue oh
yeah yes yes
listen
which you know given the diversity of
panasonic is not not a surprise right
but this kind of open activity where
you've tried to open out to
new partnerships with universities and
so forth
how new is that when did that really
start to become more popular in
panasonic
oh
now they are i'll see we have our
adventure group there or some uh house
organization
which has some
responsibility
to find uh some new you know technology
on the outside and also they try to
connect
each other so we have some kind of
function
okay yeah let's open the floor again
uh i'm a phd student i'm a medical
science engineering uh my phd distortion
justifies the ever prominent role of a
major oem company as an rmb collaborator
so this talk was uh closely related with
my research interests
um so uh my question is how does
panasonic uh plan to manage its
knowledge base once one is acquired once
it's acquired um how do panasonic's r d
uh policy translate to its goal of
producing supply risk
or um does palestine just plan to
commoditize its knowledge base like
worldcom and just keep a portfolio what
do you mean by commoditizing the
knowledge base
so explain that so
so it seems to me that you know
research is so diverse and you know so
across i mean so large
economies and sectors
that
um
i mean
i i would like to understand i mean how
directly related are these for you know
panasonic's markets or panasonic
suppliers
that is yeah or or is panasonic just you
know doing the scientific for the sake
of anandi to sell it as you know
knowledge base
right now the uh
uh each company
has our own around the group
and then for the fourth company that's
right yes
so
within the year our house here five
years
uh
a business with the five years from now
on the uh they have a responsibility to
do by myself
so the rationality of
responsibility of the corporate only is
that to make our
uh
new house topics
to produce a new uh business other than
the uh uh the one the uh uh four
companies is not working
so
yeah it's a very broad switch very hard
you know which one is uh you know
correct or not
so other times we have to definitely
uh focus on here which area we should go
so that's our right now the uh our big
big problem to decide yeah so also in
terms of knowledge base you're talking
people not just patents and so forth
right
what is panasonic's attitude toward say
hiring people from outside or
you know once a collaboration is
finished what happens to the people who
are involved in it
oh the the people from the panasonic
yeah are they they are
maybe to the uh next project yes yeah or
different areas yeah okay okay
uh as
as a fellow in
panasonic what keeps you up at night now
what do you worry about
yeah uh as i told you the uh i can't
define it by myself to my role
so the i always you know think about
in my work am i right you know am i do a
right thing or not you know
you know
so
always i
ask me by myself you know i'm correct or
not as well
because the uh
sometimes of course i have to think
about a new technology
but all the people already working
so you know there are some
you know competition
competitively and also they are usually
uh
people who work working very hard
is
they don't like their new technology
so they want to keep their
own you know
the technology they're working already
already
so
it's very hard to change you know
getting people to switch over to kill
one project and start another yeah i
think that must be the hardest job in r
d management
uh
great questions
so you talk about three different types
of collaboration for our
continuations uh can you generalize and
say what uh talk about some of the key
factors for success
in a collaborative relationship i mean
you talk about we mean but yeah can you
be more specific
ah
yeah that's a difficult one too
uh
it's not a
horse
a rule
however
when you look at the houses spectral
technology specular point of view
probably the academia is a
person narrowest
and next one is a project
venture group adventure company and they
are personal a kind of broad area
so
if you apply the new
topics working with the uh these three
kind of the a partner
you know which one you you need you know
if you need a more you know narrow
spectrum maybe you should go to the
university or some professor but if you
you know
make a
project
to transfer the market at the first
possible
maybe you should go the uh some personal
company or something like that
yes so other times probably
uh our industry
may make effort
as much possible otherwise they don't
care about your business so much you
know the professor really likes their
own research so
we have to work very hard yeah
do you see panasonic having different
expectations for
the young people it hires
into r d
are they expecting more english language
skills are they expecting other kind of
skills that didn't used to be there
you can see the miners
so they listen to the
english
necessary
necessary but are you seeing changes or
is panasonic intentionally trying to
hire more foreigners for instance
yeah probably they will hire the more uh
foreign people than the japan
non-japanese people yeah because they
are we care about the more global
expansion
so the uh from this the uh
uh i think
a couple of couple years ago
we're gonna
increase the number of the
people from the the foreign company
country okay
for go ahead
i've worked for panasonic in osaka and
i've used many of your products i love
the company because the products are
very robust and high quality but i
wonder from your words
what are the core competencies of
panasonic being such a diverse company
when you get together with your business
team and you talk about your business
plan
moving away from the cell phones and
digital electronics because it's so such
short time frame right you must be
talking about your core competencies of
the company
i'm curious from your perspective what
what are they
uh right now they are crossing is uh
uh first thing i can say is the uh
our asset of the technology of the
consumer mix
yes
but uh
there are a lot
you know the products are very you know
diverse
so the uh
what what i want to say is that we're
gonna
say
uh
expand here
uh the industry area i mean the b2c
the number of b2c
is uh may be maintained however we the
number of the business of the b2b
is a
to using our core you know
technology or color assets you know
let me kind of follow up on that with
you know some of your slides show that
the cloud is very important to these new
areas of growth
for panasonic what's the cloud are you
mostly is the company mostly a cloud
user are you providing data center
services or
what's the cloud for the company
yeah and frankly this is personal
opinion you don't have to anything you
know disclaimer should have been said
yeah this is your personal opinion
yeah in fact you still you are thinking
about you know per user or your provider
but
but basically
we're manufacturing company
so
probably the uh
we
we have to you know use a cloud with
other technology
and then
we have to
improve the our product
if the uh you know double product
connect with the network
to optimize the system
maybe we have to
change
some function or design or you know
so those stuff
if the those you know are changing
uh it happened maybe we can make a new
you know business area
and that's another factor for timing
with the market yeah you know everyone
knows that cars are becoming more
interconnected and other things are
becoming more interconnected but when
does the air conditioner become
interconnected right
how involved is uh panasonic in creating
its future also uh suppliers and i mean
let it be equipment suppliers materials
of lines i mean
these are ideas done for creating the
future businesses
i guess it should go hand in hand with
creating the future suppliers right and
and the future marketplace
so what kind of uh
initiatives are going on so the question
is
joint development leads to a supplier
relationship and so what kind of is
there a set process for that is that
your okay
can you leave it to the open universal
or
normal business style either way
and again this is personal
generally of course we have a marketing
group
so they know they already you know they
know what they try to know the
uh
what happened in the market
so they are sometimes they request us
here some new product
and also the uh
each company has a rnd and they are they
have a new already new uh making a new
technology so we're looking at you know
both side and then we decide okay we go
this way well that way
yeah and around the case here
where how
you we're using the uh
uh
the information of
the technology trend and also the market
trend
using the uh outside you know some sort
of institute or
you know or but
i was doing by ourselves
and then
and look at here that the society and
then look at the trend of the technology
we're going to decide okay we'll take
this one away
yeah did you have one oh yeah so
in one of your early slides i'm i want
to make sure i understood it correctly
i'm not sure i did it was in addressing
the
problem of the ever-shortening life
cycle of process and
how you deal with that and
there was a line that says something
about introducing many themes to the
market or many i think the word was
themes
and so my question is that referring to
who would contrast say that what you
might call the apple model with the
samsung model and
sorry to use a bad word
stop no go ahead and explain what you
mean this is a recent article i was very
interesting apple always focuses on
bringing it one or most two new products
at a time because that with an iphone
maybe the last example i have 5s 5c
but to put everything into that product
and assume they understand what the
market wants and they will put all their
develop
samsung will introduce many models of
smartphones and let the market pick
which they think is the best and some
will fall by the wayside some will be
very successful so is that your idea
that you would introduce multiple
variations of a product and
try to let the market sort it out rather
than predict what the market wants did i
understand that correctly
so actually while you're thinking about
that i want to comment because years ago
in one of these seminars somebody was
comparing sony and nec
two big japanese electronics companies
pointed out that sony tried to hit home
runs with single products and that nec
awarded it gave awards to its r d people
for finding the most new things you
could do with a new technology
so it's very similar kind of you know
sort of cultural difference between the
the two approaches
yeah both companies do
and i didn't uh wondered whether this
whether i had understood when you
yeah maybe that that graph
is the uh
i'll say
true for the
our company size
if the
samsung ksdr of course
they also use a digital product and also
they are
they also struggle with the uh this high
high price competition
however
they have a house say
enough investment
for their factory or you know they can
continue
the investment
that's a one way
for them for for something to win
and the apple case
are different
i think
the
if you compare to the
laser project
product or uh the
analog project
the analog product
is very stronger than the digital
product product about as for the uh
house
price competition
because here they have a not easy
uh another product
cannot easily you know
made by the
anyone
so they keep the price
and uh
i guess their uh apple case
of course they earned money uh from the
hardware however the their house
user interface or
you know such kind of stuff is a
a kind of the uh analog area
not
ui i i just migrate my opinion
ui
is a not a digital area you are the
probability uh analog lady because it
very depends on the
feeling or you know
so
they
they have restaurant about
that area
so they succeed with the uh
those models right i guess
interesting okay now
go ahead
i noticed uh in your project that you
have the semiconductor
work in
your portfolio
since uh semiconductor right now your 45
nanometer is
way behind but
so with panasonic's
amount of
device requirement can you really afford
a very expensive semiconductor
manufacturer yes yes
so are you right yeah we also very
struggle with the uh the business of the
semiconductor
so now the
we
about the system in society we now focus
on the only the designing we don't
completely follow light or fabulous
five years from now what will panasonic
look like will it change
will panasonic be pretty much the same
kind of company five years from now or
will it really seem different do you
think oh this is probably different
from now right yeah five years later
yeah probably
yeah we have changed
okay okay yeah
go ahead
so according to your presentation and
according to our knowledge panasonic is
clear it's very innovative with high ind
investment every year but
i'm very curious why
in recent years
not only panasonic but also toshiba and
the sony and
the shop and they all suffer the
very huge losses
so do can you explain why
they are very innovative but
with the
branded market
so what's your opinion
uh
you know they are the
innovators
yeah yes but in japan they are you know
right now they are too kind you know
hidachi and toshiba mitsubishi
there was one group probably and the
sony and the panasonic and the sharp
is another
different group because a lot of
groupies are mainly for work on the uh
consumer electronics yeah and the other
you know
first one is uh
not only consumer maybe the uh b2b is a
main business so
they must move to the
more healthy
stable
market
not easy to join however after joined
it's a very stable area
so so the
second group
probably
they
those companies are
how to find out
more house
b2b or
those
business area
i guess they'll move to there yeah
other questions go ahead
your product as well sonya you have
always developed a very you know
advanced product but those days in order
to do that not only rmd having you need
more
advanced
different types of people like in second
body people change the job frequently
right
and so then sing some songs i see most
key people it's not difficult korean
educated people from here
many japanese companies like typically
your company is only
most employed almost the right time most
of people right you join the company for
23 years it's very difficult to create
you know develop innovative products
this person is going to change adding
more people from here from different
countries otherwise i think you're gonna
your company is going to be
the same no
not only my company but also disabled
company also a japanese company also
think about the diversity or you know
they were more healthy new blood
to to join the uh you know a new blood
or you know different idea you know
that's kind of mixing it sounds like a
crazy idea maybe 100 people from you
know
and your company will be changed
thank you
there are a lot of initiatives like that
go ahead
well i actually have a one question
about the panasonic display which i i
think i heard like back last year
panasonic has announced that it just
making display for plasma tv
and uh just now in one of your slides i
saw you have a oled for i think some
kind of display so how what is your
strategy
in
yeah so far they are we have a business
of the
panel business
and also set to business we have two
business
so far
but right now the uh
we feel that it's very hard
to do the
panel business
by our own company
so our strategy is that we keep the euro
a set business using the module display
module
maybe buying the other company
but uh about the panel business
difference do we have to
find some partner like our open
innovation for that you know so the flip
side of open innovation is not just
bringing in from outside it's spinning
out in the right way
you